I think this is the clip that I wanted
to discuss with Coach about what's
basically going on with social media
today and what you would call the young
men versus young women social media
disparity can we play this clip yes
through young girls develop they're
going to get a lot of attention young
boys are simply not he's gonna witness
his female counterparts on Tick Tock ten
thousand followers twenty thousand
thirty thousand million followers what
does that do to the Dynamics and the
hierarchy on campus can he get this girl
now he has no chance and he's going to
grow up with them through High School
believing I have no chance at women the
self-esteem of this kid is going to get
killed the only thing he can reach out
now to are Instagram thoughts and
pornography at a certain age yeah so a
very interesting conversation here okay
and this will have a
um
so basically if I can sum up what you're
saying 21 year old guy 21 year old girl
21 maybe you're you know a senior in
college maybe you've been working for a
couple years
um as a guy 21 year old female same
exact situation maybe you're a senior in
college maybe you're been working for a
couple years the only difference is as a
woman you can kind of uh get a lot of
eyeballs out there on the social media
platforms like it's it's taken me hard
work to get to where I'm at right now
and a girl does the exact same thing all
she has to do is put some bikini
pictures out there much easier for a
woman much easier for a woman and you're
basically saying it for a 21 year old
comparing himself trying to get another
21 year old female oh man life is going
to be tough for you brother it's a
little bit tougher than when I grew up
in the olden days in a time where a
woman probably wouldn't get maybe three
men in their entire city or county or
neighborhood or school if that she might
go to the Rival High School potentially
attention now it's a little bit more
vast there's a lot more Choice Global
sexual Marketplace and here's the funny
thing uh my young lady here in the
Natalia Natalia she mentioned this
earlier because she's in the dating
Minefield she says you know she has a
lot of options
I get a lot of offer both ways she's
beautiful and she should and what we but
what we have to understand is as young
men this is where I position myself as
young men
typically 70 percent of men tend to be
invisible to the world until they as you
said put in a Year's 20 years worth of
work and then it's easy for you to hop
on social media with the Bugatti and the
Lamborghini and you handsome and you got
your beard in and you got all of that
stuff oh you can jump on now and you can
get a lot of attention but that's a
waiting game that men at this particular
point I'm gonna say based on the
pornography industry being a billion
dollar industry no young men are
consuming it based on Instagram I can
put a post up on Instagram ain't nobody
gonna like it but if a young woman just
comes in and gives her what murder the
Nature has blessed her with or what the
Miracles of modern science has injected
into her now she gonna get a whole bunch
of attention and then that puts me in
that same age group at a significant
disadvantage that people aren't
addressing I don't like when people
complain about it I just presented as a
reality in the situation and until the
the porn industry becomes bankrupt my
opinion is going to be true well what
about athletes now so male athletes
which is a very small attention they get
far more attention than women and that's
another thing off their what God grace
gave them is their athletic abilities
it's the same thing and it's the same
thing and I also have to ask I just your
Instagram thought comment obviously I'm
on Instagram I post bikini pics and Tick
Tock thought whatever it is my Instagram
Tick Tock thought to you I mean am I the
person you're just when you say that am
I the category or something I mean
that's how you make your money right
that's how you that's how you better
what is a thought to you hold on let me
come back let me let me come back and
answer something here um when we talk
about athletes and male athletes I
actually addressed this and I addressed
it this morning far more
male athletes tend to fall into the same
category as female people who get uh
attention however I think they're way
however watch this watch this watch this
what percentage of men are successful
female athletes versus successful female
successful male athletes
what percentage of males are successful
male athletes very small 0.000 very very
small now what percentage of young
worlds jumped on Tick Tock and went on
there and got 100 what do you consider
successful though because there's a lot
of people that have millions of
followers and I know some of these girls
they don't make nothing like that that's
the track well I don't even have that
much followers who would never think I
make but that is the Trap that I'm
trying to make you aware see we showed a
20-second clip and you're trying to jump
all of this and you're saying what about
this and what about that well you said
Instagram thoughts you said Tick Tock
thoughts but that doesn't mean you're
making money that doesn't mean you're
making money you could just be getting
attention is that a problem if a woman
gets attempt men's get attention from
various things was that a problem very
small percentage of men get attention in
comparison yeah I mean this is this is
not even an argument I mean listen you
could probably no I would agree this is
absolutely agree out the normal average
woman can get way more
than a male normal average male which
puts the percentages at if we just want
to be General 70 of the men are
consuming and paying attention to a
majority of women as opposed to the
opposite yeah when it when it comes to
women on social media they are producers
more than they are consumers and if they
do consume they might be consuming a
makeup Channel they might be consuming
something they're not consuming the vast
the the vast majority of male athletes
that have even succeeded because even
those guys have to jump through hoops
and hurdles when he jumps in his DM that
woman probably would get more attention
if she made a video and said these
basketball players are in my DMs as
opposed to her even getting married to
that guy today that's where the problem
let me hone in on this because I want to
tell you a story but is your the reason
that you're doing this is to is to do
what to basically inform men Hey guys
you're gonna have to get in line and
wait your turn yeah well that's gonna
have to grow up and become yes the man I
mean because that was an hour and a half
speech yeah they took that 20 seconds
from well so there's more exactly
exactly okay so the broader argument is
money energy attention and time gotcha
over time men have to kind of work for
their position in life and this isn't a
complaint a lot of people think oh these
red pill guys are complaining it ain't
gonna be any different anytime soon
especially with social media but the
reality is you're gonna have to put in
that work you're gonna have to apply
yourself to get to that position uh
because at the time and I also tell men
the generation of women that you're
trying to date they're not your women
correct I say that that's that's not
what do you mean by that which means
you're going after you're a 21 year old
man yeah man you're trying to impress a
21 year old woman who has access to a
hope I'd say really focus on yourself
and then when you're 30 go get a 21 year
old because at that point you have the
what leverage and options let me give
you one story okay of why I appreciate
what you're saying with this okay
um I'm 18 years old I'm a senior in high
school there's this girl at a different
high school that I am obsessed with okay
I'm like yo bro what's up with so and so
you know I'm telling my I'm like this is
we don't have cell phones we got social
media I'm trying to use like old school
carrier pigeon for my boy to holler on
my behalf okay and
um this girl deserved a lot of attention
at the time okay rightfully so at that
time she was 17 I was 18 okay
long story short I find out that sorry
bro she's not interested she's dating so
and so who's already in college that's
driving a you know a BMW and I'm like
life's not fair bro I love this girl I
can't believe it like life sucks fast
forward I see that same girl at a
birthday party for a friend of mine's
40th birthday party okay we also and I'm
like and I go
wow she don't look so good I said oh the
life's been kind of rough to this girl
uh great girl but
I'm glad that I didn't get what I wanted
when I was 18 years old okay and since
then I've gotten
that girl times ten a million okay but
it but in guys are very myopic when
you're 18 you want oh my God I want that
right if you're willing to wait the time
and invest and improve upon yourself
when you're 30 or when you're 40 and
your sexual market value Peak and you've
taken care of you know your physicality
your mentality your pocketbooks now the
world's your oyster it's just very hard
when you're young to realize that well
it's hard and also you have the you have
you know mother nature and father time
playing a cruel game on you hyping you
up on uh testosterone which is a
powerful drug which is a need for you to
have it now and a lot of guys don't want
to wait they don't want to hear me say
slow down no slow down they like I want
to now tell me how to get it now exactly
and then you kind of get walked down a
trap that you cannot dig out of or it
might take you 20 years and here's the
difference between back then and now is
that there was no social media then
right so she was getting hollered out by
the 21 year old cool guy that picked her
up in the BMW now it's that guy and I
lived in Miami so that guy in Miami is
hollering at her
but now it's guys in in Dubai and
Australia and Europe in London flight
offering these women everything so women
have the advantage Ali you're gorgeous
you're married don't get offended women
have the advantage from 18 to 29.
they're hot they're young they're
beautiful they're vibrant they got the
advantage men have the advantage 30 plus
30 points because it's going to take
time to become the man that you need to
become so if you like that clip click
right here to watch another or if you
want to watch the entire saucecast click
right here
foreign
[Music]